here's what would happen if mount fuji  exploded tomorrow  well you'd see a massive plume of ash  rising from the peak and you'd spy red  magma pooling along its sides  if you live on the outskirts of the city  closest to mount fuji you could watch  the lava flow slowly head toward your  house setting fires along the way  ash would start to rain down on tokyo  departing flights would be grounded  indefinitely and you wouldn't be able to  drive either within 24 hours the city  would effectively shut down  the contaminated air would make your  eyes red and itchy if you inhaled too  much you could eventually develop  silicosis a condition that could  permanently impair your lungs ordinary  life would be nearly impossible in the  aftermath of this eruption  globally it would disrupt supply chains  around the world since no ships would be  able to navigate tokyo bay so